here comes my Missouri homeboy there you
go yes indeed what we got for this
weekend Paul oh you know there's a
little game going on this is all just
Preamble not nobody's like let's there's
there's one show in town this week and
this ain't it you gonna be in the house
I uh I'm gonna go I'm I won't enjoy like
here's the thing and this is what I
realized like I don't
I don't enjoy the games unless it's just
a blowout from the opening kickoff which
it never is
um the up and down the back and forth
and hopefully it's competitive and all
that but it's an awful awful feeling
until the game is over and if you win
it's the best so it's like the worst
feeling that you can have having a great
feeling if your team wins oh my mother's
still not speaking to me because I
wouldn't let her go last weekend it was
too cold I wouldn't let her sit I'm like
Mom no it's too cold for you to sit in
the stairs just watch at home yeah she's
still not speaking to me you're an
Avenger
you have a daughter
but you've lost a lot of time
like me
first things first I just talked to
Peyton and I said what
what out the movie how are they gonna do
that to the sexiest man alive I think he
did everybody a favor
no indeed he said you had a bathtub
scene in the second when we got a little
bit here they had a little Marvin Gaye
sing along to you on the film I mean we
needed that yeah it's you know it's I'm
all for efficiency and you know making a
movie as short as it can possibly be so
anytime you cut anything I'm okay with
it you worked hard I know you worked
hard on your body I worked harder than
I've ever worked just to look oh
when ant-man's off the Ant-Man diet
what's
I mean I just you know you live like a
normal human being okay yeah okay all
right now Kevin feige has already dubbed
Jonathan Majors an iconic villain in the
Marvel Universe to the likes of Thanos
what makes Kang the Conqueror iconic and
Jonathan yeah I mean it's you know I
think that Jonathan is one of those like
actors and you see his performances like
I can't imagine anybody else doing that
uh because he has such gravitas and and
power and you know Kang is a conqueror
so it's pretty yeah it's pretty cool to
see it's fun to act opposite and um and
I think audiences uh are gonna dig it
yes I'm sure we're gonna dig it I can't
wait to see it tonight and I also can't
wait to see this season of only murders
in the building Selena Gomez had us all
losing our minds when first of all she
reveals you and then Meryl Streep yeah
I agree I don't know it's the most it's
the most amazing thing to be and to be
in that room Selena is great and I've
worked with Selena and she's a really
good friend of mine uh adore her
Martin Short and Steve Martin are Mount
Rushmore
Andrea Martin was in that room and for
any comedy fan or uh I mean she's
she is such she's like a home run hitter
I can't believe that I'm in the room
with Andrea Martin and then you pan over
and it's Meryl Streep so uh yeah a bit
of a
a bit of a Powerhouse do you get lost in
the sauce when all of that is in the
room or there's there's uh
there's just that oh I don't I don't
want to get in the way of anything and I
also just really acknowledge how great
they are I have many I can't believe I'm
in this room right now moments
he shows up yeah it's great I mean
talk about another Legend
[Music]